- The first time I took
ecstasy was in Manchester.
I was thinking, what is this?
This is pretty boring.
Then all of a sudden my knees
just completely buckle and time
just started to stand still.
[music playing]
The whole room is just throbbing
and everybody's dancing.
And the music's just
pulsing into my head.
All these beeps
and weird noises,
like signals from outer space
that I didn't understand
now completely making sense.
I never wanted the party
to end after that night.
Raving became my religion.
I'm Shaun Attwood, known as
one of the biggest ecstasy
traffickers in
the US rave scene.
My local nickname
was English Shaun.
I was up against one of the Cosa
Nostras most notorious killers.
[music playing]
As a young person, I set a goal
to be a millionaire by age 30.
Greed is good was my mantra.
I flew out to Arizona because
it dazzled me as a teenager.
The plane comes in, you're
looking out the window,
and you're seeing
all these swimming
pools in people's backyards.
The sun's always shining,
it's almost 50 degrees
in the summer.
And as soon as they
hear the English accent
they roll out the red carpet.
But the rave scene
was barely starting.
They didn't even know what
ecstasy was so there was
this huge gap in the market.
[crowd cheering]
When I threw my first rave,
looking down at all the ravers
just going off, with the
strobe lights pulsing,
I knew that this was
my calling in life.
[music playing]
- It's quarter to
six in the morning!
[crowd cheering]
- As an experiment I decided
to order 1,000 pills out of LA.
All the stuff goes
in one weekend.
I've made thousands
of dollars just
like that, partying my ass off.
And that was when I decided
to go full-time trafficking.
[music playing]